us-backed forces in syria have launched
an assault on what they call the last
ISIL held area near the Iraqi border our
T's Arabic channel got a glimpse of life
in the village of the bug loose
[Music]
name an abra Palala me personally
Milosevic who survived National Islamic
Azad holiday Sarah for the holiday that
me that convey Sharon life taken my
lemon has your new Google
[Music]
Redeemer the sentiment ahead a European
Lenten day - the piano a delusion - maja
- da da do do da y la Fiera let me a
subpoena
Alice damn you've been a killer for this
Damian the village of buggers has been a
hot spot for the Syrian democratic
forces for several weeks
they say hundreds of civilians withdrew
from the area a day before the attack
most were children and women some of
whom gave birth while married to ISIL
fighters a Syrian democratic forces
spokesman claims the operation will be
swift guess tf's been advancing on two
fronts into - held territory since
yesterday evening heavy clashes are
taking place at the moment
three SDF fighters are wounded so far no
information on Isis casualties yet we
expect it to be over soon the author of
inside Syria Rhys Ulrich spoke with us
earlier he thinks the u.s. overestimates
its role in defeating Islamic state
especially after Donald Trump had
already declared it mission complete
just a couple of days ago we just took
over you know you kept hearing it was
90% 92% the Caliphate in Syria now it's
a hundred percent we just took over 100%
caliphate
that means the area of the land would
just have a hundred percent as usual
president Trump is playing fast and
loose with the truth and he tends to
exaggerate things and I was interesting
to me that he said we have taken back
control I think there's a strong view in
Washington that the u.s. is now
controlling parts of Syria not something
that either the SDF for the Syrian
people are interested in having long
term the u.s. didn't hasn't defeated
completely anyone the problem is it's
even if - is defeated as a force
controlling actual territory it has its
origins is a terrorist group training
suicide bombers having small-cell
actions the danger is that they go back
to what they were originally doing and
carry out these kinds of terrorist
attacks which are very difficult to stop
I think Trump's instincts are to pull
troops out of Syria
and Afghanistan in order to ratchet up
u.s. aggression in places like Iran and
Venezuela you can't continue to occupy
other countries indefinitely when the
people of those countries don't want you
there and that's certainly in the
situation in both Syria and in
Afghanistan stay tuned
each day there could be a new
development that's the thing about the
Trump administration
you